p g et puis je vous le disais hier il
n'y a pas que le football au stade de
france aujourd'hui il y à aussi en ce
moment un défilé de 300 mannequins
organisé sur le stade pour célébrer les
40 ans de création du couturier yves
saint laurent c'est un événement qui en
précède un autre est la marne ou
c'est sans doute le plus beau casting
jamais imaginé qui vient de pénétrer sur
la pelouse du stade de france les belles
filles du monde avec des noms qui font
rêver carla bruni et issiaka ça adriana
la fiancée 42 elle défile tout depuis
quelques minutes
au rythme du boléro de ravel revu et
corrigé par les tambours de métal boys
quinze minutes de rêve offert par yves
saint-laurent spectateurs du mondial
pour célébrer ses 40 ans de haute
couture
un défilé unique puisque vous voyez
rassemblés ici froissant mannequin elle
porte des robes d'exception choisi par
l'île saint laurent lui même par lui les
4000 pièces de sa collection personnelle
c'est d'ailleurs un peu la vie du
couturier qui défilent en ce moment même
devant les 80000 spectateurs du stade de
france ses créations rappelle en effet
son amour pour la peinture avec de
nombreux modèles inspirés de picasso
matisse ou van gogh rien à d'ailleurs
été laissé au hasard pour ce défilé
unique
ainsi les top modèles portent des
chaussures spécialement conçus pour ne
pas abîmer la pelouse
la pelouse qui est d'ailleurs vos
couverte d'une toile décoré de nuages
bleus sur la pelouse bleu dans le ciel
c'est peut-être un heureux présage pour
l'équipe de france
retour au football et au bras